All right, so
now that we're back from our aside,
let's go back to thinking about this
applications program interface.
So I talked about planning and
I talked about learning.
And it turns out that there's
two other sub-processes or
sub-components that might
be useful to think about
that kind of relate these
quantities together differently.
One is the notion of a modeler.
What a modeler can do
is take transitions and
build a modeler out of it.
>> That makes sense.
>> And a simulator is kind of the
inverse, where you can take a model and
you can use it to generate transitions.
You can actually kind of imagine
running around in the world,
Just by simulating that row.
This is generally not
a very hard thing to do.
Though there's certainly applications
of reinforcement learning where this
simulator is extremely expensive.
Because it's simulating a lot
of things in the world.
And this modeling problem you
can think of again as a kind of
machine learning problem.
Right?
Trying to map this kind of information
into models.
>> So you call them sub-processes.
Does this mean that one way to do
learning would be to do modeling and
simulating so that I had models.
And I knew what the reinforcement
function was, and
then I could just do planning?
>> Yeah, that's a really good idea.
In fact, let's look at different ways
of gluing these things together.
>> Okay.